madame jamie avait bien mis vingt ans
pour rattraper le retard imposé par la
première mouture d'un gouvernement
taliban a tant que proches quand j'étais
petit la situation ne m'a pas permis
d'étudier les écoles étaient fermées
nous vivions sous les règles sévères des
talibans seraient tassart total des buts
les avec la constance du jardinier
celles qui étaient illettrés est devenu
duc et femme est seule elle s'est lancé
en affaires
une entreprise de produits alimentaires
étaient une source directe et indirecte
de revenus pour une centaine d'employés
seuls 4000 mètres une source de revenus
et de fierté mais avec le retour au
pouvoir des talibans ce n'était plus
possible tout genre à tottenham et chef
ce n'est pas possible de faire des
affaires en se cachant ou en se couvrant
vous ne pouvez pas faire des affaires en
portant la burqa personne ne nous
encourage ou ne nous soutient nous avons
tout perdu
ce qui lui reste de marinade d'épicés
d'herbes séchées accumule la poussière
chez elle
à l'époque j'aurais la star ils sont
ignorants ils ne savent rien ils ont
vécu dans les montagnes et garder leurs
femmes comme des esclaves
dans le centre commercial réservé aux
femmes qu'elle a fondée avec l'aide de
dons étrangers une boutique sur deux est
fermée et les clientes se font rares
pour celle qui s'accroche
c'est ici que fazia propose des services
de couture on sent toute l'amertume de
cette femme bachelière souligne-t-elle
qui n'a d'autre choix aujourd'hui pour
soutenir une famille entière
et ne compte plus qu elle a perdu avec
l'arrivée au pouvoir des talibans son
fils aîné est mort l'autre se cache à la
maison son mari aussi les avoir été
emprisonné six mois par les nouveaux
souverain ses deux filles n'ont plus
droit à une éducation
je suis la seule à pouvoir soutenir ma
famille alors que nous souffrons d'une
situation désastreuse
nous ne sommes pas en sécurité que vous
mes chers et la peur au ventre ne la
quitte jamais elle tend les mains dont
elle n'arrive plus à calmer les
tremblements
nous sommes prisonnière d'une situation
sans fuite possible nous y sommes
coincés physiquement mais aussi
mentalement toutes les femmes souffrent
de dépression et nous avons mal
la dépression c'est un mot qui revient
souvent dans les conversations avec les
femmes afghanes mais malgré tout
plusieurs d'entre elles continuent de
vouloir envoyer un message clair aux
talibans malgré toutes les répressions
vous ne parviendrez pas nous faire
reculer complètement 20 ans derrière et
c'est un message qu'elle envoie d'abord
ici dans la rue
on les croise un peu à hirak près de la
frontière avec l'iran mais surtout dans
les rues grouillantes de kaboul
elles ont le visage découvert parfois
maquiller et elles n'ont pas l'intention
de se couvrir plus qu'elles ne le font
déjà une forme de résistance à
l'imposition décrété par les talibans il
ya un mois
athenes il n'y a pas de meilleur hidjab
que ça nous avons des problèmes plus
importants il n'y a pas de travail pour
les gens les talibans devraient créer
des emplois ils ne paient pas les
salaires
selon le décret émis par les talibans
ces femmes qui refusent de se conformer
à une tenue islamique qui est selon eux
correct c'est à dire qu'elle couvre tout
le visage sauf les yeux expose les
hommes de leur famille à la prison ce
code vestimentaire obligé n'est que la
dernière des restrictions de plus en
plus sévères imposées aux femmes
afghanes
après les avoir bannis de la vie
politique et de la fonction publique
ils ont aussi empêché les femmes de
monter à bord de vols nationaux ou
internationaux 101 maram un tuteur
masculin
ce n'est pas son métier mais après avoir
perdu son travail de bureau et renoncer
à se présenter en classe à l'université
azita ne se voyait pas rester cloîtrés à
la maison à ne rien faire
les talibans affirment respecter et
défendre les droits des femmes azita les
voies plutôt disparaître un à un
comme directement comment peuvent-ils
prétendre défendre le droit des femmes
éducation et la base de nos droits comme
pour les hommes l'éducation d'une femme
est essentiel pour la société les
familles ont besoin de femmes éduquées
hasard tronic
elle donne de son temps pour enseigner
clandestinement à des femmes
analphabètes et surtout à ses filles
c'est là qu'ils les talibans interdisent
désormais l'accès aux bancs d'école
[Musique]
on voit le désir et l'intérêt des filles
pour leurs études chacune d'entre elles
avaient un objectif mais la motivation
qu'elle avait a été anéantie quand les
écoles ont fermé
cela fait maintenant 2 167 jours que les
filles sont tes vingt sept écoles dès la
6e année les promesses répétées du
gouvernement taliban de les réintégrer
dans les classes c'est maintenant une
année scolaire complet dont ils ont été
privés
dounia parcourent des kilomètres pour
venir ici malgré l'interdiction
pourquoi devrais-je avoir peur le temps
d'étudier c'est maintenant si on ne le
fait pas maintenant nous serons vieille
et nous ne pourrons pas poursuivre notre
éducation total et bata ces lettres de
rabat et
les derniers résistants de l'afghanistan
ce sont les femmes dit celle qui ont
bien voulu se confier elle s'accroche
chaque jour au présent déterminés à
sauver leur avenir ici marie ève bédard
radio-canada kabylie